I think that where bodies simply have
states as part of them you have a
dynamic where one kind of agent with one
kind of incentive structure is supposed
to be checking and that they're supposed
to be checking and balancing each other
which as we know stakes states like to
avoid certain kinds of embarrassment
they like to do things in the green room
there are all sorts of things that can
go on this so what part of what I favor
is the introduction of other kinds of
entities whether these are significant
groups are representing nonprofits or
significant groups representing business
even chambers of commerce I believe that
having different kinds of stakeholders
with a different kind of incentives at
the table in these institutions can have
a very profound impact it brings
different information to light it
creates incentives to take care of
populations that may not you may not
have taken care of by just States or
just corporations or just NGOs for that
matter so I think that's the first thing
now the practical implication of that if
you look at some of the world's courts
only states have standing what's called
your stand I before those some of those
courts and if you gave other kinds of
entities the ability to approach those
courts certain other things would be put
on the agenda and actually if it's those
courts do have the capacity to take on
many many more cases so it is possible
to introduce those different kinds of
agents who can bring cases to the court
and have the court deliver on that it's
not going to overwhelm the courts
secondly you could look at the UN
various kinds of bodies where I believe
and this is quite a radical proposal
that you should have these whether it's
the chambers of commerce that are
international or nonprofit bodies at the
table articulating their view and in
fact it already happens informally to a
limited extent but it doesn't have the
kind of bite that it needs to have for
us to have a different kind of global
order that is more responsive to the
needs of people
you